I need a call I need to join Goomy's discord creepy all
right I'm in I need to wait for Goomy to get here hey should
I hello hello Goomy what's up stupid what's up bitch can you
join my club I'm gonna create a club right now oh okay I
made my own already what the fuck Goomy can i join your club
what's your club called guess pick a guess um um spin my
mouth i'm gonna get to throw what the fuck right what the
this is like like like hunger games you know district i mean
it's what the fuck is that what is that oh yeah you you're
gross how do you live this.
Wait, we're the where's the loot?
Oh shit, there's so much in the middle.
Oh shit!
My loot now.
Hey, this map is so pretty.
Wait, is he fighting someone?
Fuck if I know.
I don't know what's going on.
Where are you, Gumi?
Where am I?
I'm heading towards the circle.
What the fuck are these people?
Are those my teammates?
So there's There's no enemies in this mother, is that what
you're telling me?
Like, who is this?
Hey.
Oh, I'm teammates!
Let me see.
Yeah, I'm teammates.
Like, you'll see, like, teammate shadows and stuff.
Like, you see the, yeah, see, look.
This guy, like, hey.
He thinks he can shoot me.
His name is Ching-Goo.
Aw, that means run.
Can we- It's preview preview map is to preview mode is to
explore the map.
There's no fighting But holes, but holes get in the bow.
I am.
I'm what the fuck.
This is a long ass but hole.
Oh no chingoo He's dead chingoo.
Yeah, how's he dead?
He fell.
He fucking fell Oh my god, wait, is that a car?
Wait, that's a car wait That guy got a car Wait, are you
fighting them Who needs popping on?
Are you actually They're right here 34 and lifeline.
Wait, watch this.
Just standing here my gas.
Standing here my gas.
I cracked him.
He's flush.
Hey, I'm one.
I'm kind of one.
He's one too.
He's leaving.
All right.
I'm a big fish.
He can't see me.
He doesn't.
Oh, he sees me!
I think it's all you.
Oh my god, I can't climb.
He's going.
Oh, you stupid bitch.
You can climb up here.
Stupid.
Now I'm just in the open.
You climb up.
You should have climbed up
I got I got one Wait Pathfinder's a bloodhounds one
bloodhounds one
Hey, I need help Gumi this guy this one guy just shoot him
this shoot don't let him
Gumi are you okay?
Are you okay?
What do you mean, Mikey?
What do you mean?
I don't even...
Bye, Gumi!
No, no, no, no, no.
Watch this, watch.
You shoot me.
Thanks for the blue.
Don't you come back here and gas me and then kill me.
Why am I crawling so fast?
Don't you...
They can't shoot me.
Wait, wait a minute, guys.
Hi, Gumi.
I think they're coming over.
Whoa!
Why do you guys have to shoot it though because oh my god
look at my look at this monster right here All right, get in
here.
Oh my god, look at this.
Look at this.
Wait, can I fit there?
Here, look at this.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Wait, where are they?
I think the gas cans are lagging the car Oh shit Wait Look
at that Whoa I'm sorry
I didn't know I didn't know
I thought I would make it I'm sorry
Okay Me Me
Okay, um, I don't think I should try, guys.
I think it's a one-by-one guy.
I have so much cookies.
I have some help here.
Yeah.
Where are you?
No, please.
Please.
What do you mean?
There's two?
Oh, he has a bug!
Oh my god, please.
SETO!
Please!
Hey, can someone shoot at this man that is shooting at me?
Okay, never mind, it's fine.
I did, and I missed every shot.
I just want you to know.
And I have this.
I did, and I missed every shot.
I'm so sorry.
Who the fuck told me to play caustic?
Who's wrong with you guys?
You.
you didn't wait what the fuck yo i can walk up top take bumi
i'm taking your shit above you please please it's just an
armor don't worry please all you have been doing is bringing
me pain pain and suffering and love you love you love me
right no i love you no all right who wants to get all right
guys get in get in bumi please I'm gonna loot anybody!
Come on, get in.
Oh wait, wait, wait.
Hey, Sesto, get in.
See, Sesto trashed me.
She's gonna run me over.
Oh, I can't run you over like that.